the number of ways that the Republican
Party differs from the Democratic party
um
numerous Myriad ways and I'm not just
talking about policy I'm not talking
about uh economic policies that are
vastly different relative to taxation or
just monetary policy in general I'm not
talking about social issues and the
respect and regard we have for our
fellow human beings the the more
humanist Outlook I'm not talking about
that
right now I'm talking specifically about
the manner with which we hold our
leaders accountable
or in in the in the way of the
Republicans in the manner in which they
do not enter Andrew Cuomo last week
Leticia James the New York State
Attorney General
concluded a lengthy investigation into
the behavior the conduct of Governor
Andrew Cuomo
and they found that he has acted
inappropriately possibly criminally
related to female staffers
that went beyond locker room talk like
Republicans like to call it he actually
reached under women's blouses and
assaulted them
now AIDS are running for the hills they
are quitting on Mass
he is a man unto himself he is an island
unto himself
he's losing support of long-time union
leaders
black political leaders in New York are
abandoning him
he's toxic
even his brother is under Fire
Melissa DeRosa this is from CNN Cuomo
top aide Melissa DeRosa resigns as
Governor faces potential impeachment
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo's top
aide Melissa DeRosa resigned late Sunday
less than a week after the release of a
report from the state attorney general
that found Cuomo's sexually harassed 11
women
quote it has been the greatest honor of
my life to serve the people of New York
for the past 10 years New Yorkers
resilience strength and optimism through
the most difficult times has inspired me
every day
DeRosa secretary to the governor said in
a statement obtained by CNN
Nancy Pelosi has called for his uh
resignation Chuck Schumer fellow New
Yorker has also called
not just them though here's Joe Biden
when asked about it also saying he
should resign
back in March you said that if the
investigation confirmed the allegations
against Governor Cuomo then he should
resign so will you now call on him to
resign given the investigators said the
11 women were credible I stand by that
statement are you now calling on him to
resign yes and if he doesn't resign do
you believe he should be impeached and
removed from office
just take one thing at a time here
I think he should
I understand that the state legislature
may decide to impeach
I don't know that for fact I've not read
all that data and he's using a photo of
you embracing him in his self-defense to
say that these are commonplace kind of
Embraces that he made and the
allegations against him do you condone
that
look I'm not going to fly spec this
I'm sure there are some Embraces that
were totally innocent
but apparently the Attorney General
decided there were things that weren't
so at this point impeachment proceeding
seem
unavoidable
uh Carl hasty is the state the the
speaker of the New York State Assembly
and they have initiated an investigation
impeachment inquiry
uh if I'm a if I'm a betting man
sometimes I am I would say that it is as
I just mentioned it's unavoidable it's
gonna happen and he will be removed
there's actually been Sheriff's offices
uh contacted or at least one where there
very well could be criminal charges
brought against
um current still Governor Andrew Cuomo
here's here's Carl Hasty discussing the
matter at a press conference
General's task completed the assembly is
working to expeditiously conclude our
investigation which covers a broad range
of issues so that we can bring this sad
chapter of our state's history to a
conclusion
as I stated last week the governor has
clearly lost the confidence of the
majority members of the New York State
Assembly
the Attorney General's report lays out
in painful detail the many instances and
ways in which he reportedly harassed and
created a hostile work environment for
the employees of the executive chamber
and others he came in contact with
I'm heartbroken let me be clear no one
should have to endure the type of
behavior detailed in the Attorney
General's report
we had a historic moment in our state's
modern history for the first time in
more than 100 years the assembly is
undertaking an impeachment investigation
of a sitting governor
chairman Levine the members of the
Judiciary Committee and my majority
colleagues understand the gravity of the
situation that we find ourselves in
today
future Generations will look to us and
how we conducted ourselves in this
moment
in order to ensure due process which is
embedded in our system we've asked for
all evidence unredacted and unfiltered
used by the Attorney General's
investigators to reach their conclusions
the process to begin receiving that
information did not begin until Saturday
evening we have not yet received all of
it we received a lot but not all of it
we've also asked the governor to submit
any relevant evidence he may have by
Friday August 13th
our goal is now to bring this matter to
a conclusion with all due haste no pun
intended
the Judiciary Committee has made
progress on the issues they have been
investigating
and to provide an update on those issues
our schedule in the progress of the
overall investigation I will now turn to
the chair of our Judiciary Committee
Charles Levine
now this is in stark contrast
to how Republicans fail
to hold their own accountable we
witnessed Marjorie Taylor green
saying abhorrent racist xenophobic
things
and being able to keep her committees if
it were up to Republicans it were was
Democrats who had to take it upon
themselves to vote her off of her
committees
she went on to to say nonsense and then
apologize about comparing the masks to
the Holocaust you may remember
and then gave a little press conference
I just learned about the Holocaust
nonsense
Matt Gates he's in hot water for
unspeakable crimes
and still nothing he still sits on the
Judiciary Committee Donald Trump the
twice impeached
president twice acquitted by Republicans
clear crimes
clear outlining of obstruction of
justice in the Mueller report nothing
incited
an attempted overthrow of the United
States government and an attempted
overturning of a free and fair election
through means not just
um violent Insurrection but also using
the mechanism the wheels and gears of
government that were at his disposal by
using the doj
as a cudgel
to attempt his insurrection
the the just say it was fraudulent
and uh I'll take care of the rest
and how do Republicans hold themselves
accountable they don't
here's Chuck Grassley
the venerable octogenarian who worked he
was he was the senator when I worked for
the Senate many years ago
he's been there forever
this is him waxing excuse making about
why Donald Trump had every right
to try to subvert the Constitution and
attempt to overthrow the government
watch this
as he would call it cockamami reasoning
the president has every right to discuss
ideas and strategies with his closest
advisors
the president whether that president is
Democrat or Republican
should feel unrestrained to bring ideas
to his closest staff
for robust discussion
eventually the facts will come out
and Trump will have to address that good
or bad
depending on the facts at hand
however
the essential question that should be
asked
what was the final decision
and that is my major concern about the
recent public comments
coming out of these interviews I've
discussed
relating to this new Trump investigation
unlike my Democratic colleagues
I won't discuss the evidence publicly at
this point in time
but let me remind the American public
with a couple already public points
did Trump fire acting Attorney General
Jeffrey Rosen
no he did not fire him
so Donald Trump according to Chuck
Grassley
has every right to counsel to gather his
his Sage advisors
Chuck Grassley is acting as though
Donald Trump making excuses acting as
though Donald Trump was just he's just
floating ideas
as though he's talking about welfare
reform or tax reform or the the
never-ending infrastructure week
president of the United States who has
raised his right hand and swore to
uphold the Constitution to Faithfully
execute his duties and support and
defend the Constitution against all
enemies foreign and domestic does not
get to foment Revolution
does not get to encourage and incite a
frothing violent mob to Insurrection to
construct a Gallow a hangman's Gallow
on the on the on the lawn of the capital
while chanting hang Mike Pence
no Senator Grassley
that is not how this works
to coin a commercial and that's not how
any of this works